We're quickly learning the full scope of what
William Barr as Donald Trump's attorney general
is expected to be doing by Donald Trump and
his cronies.
William Barr is expected and did propagandize.
Donald Trump's alleged innocence in the Russia
scandal.
William Barr is expected to interfere with
anything that might lead to Donald Trump's
taxes being provided to anybody, even state
investigators.
And most recently, William Barr was expected
and implored by Donald Trump to hold a bogus
propaganda press conference during which bar
would come out and say, Donald Trump did nothing
wrong in the Ukraine.
Joe Biden phone call fiasco.
The Washington post has a really well sourced
article, uh, by three of their top reporters
and they can now report that Donald Trump
wanted his attorney general William Barr to
hold a news conference.
And in that news conference, William Barr
was expected to say Donald Trump didn't break
any laws during the Ukraine phone call or
in anything related to that fiasco.
This happened right around the time when the
Ukraine phone call news went public and Donald
Trump put out that completely bogus partial
transcript and bar ultimately refused to do
it.
Shocking actually, and reportedly Trump and
bar are still on good terms despite Barr's
refusal.
Now, you might remember that at the time a
justice department spokeswoman said, you know,
we looked generally at whether any campaign
finance laws were likely broken by the phone
call.
We don't think any further action is warranted,
but clearly that is not what Donald Trump
wanted and clearly what Donald Trump wanted
and William bar going out and making this
declaration about Trump's vindication exceeded
the scope of what William Barr would really
be in a position to do.
You know, for a guy in Trump who has been
complaining about no due process suggesting
that an attorney general make an exonerating
legal statement, a positive exonerating legal
statement about a matter which he has not
actually investigated and which has not actually
come before the justice department in any
formal way.
That's not the legal process we have in this
country, but of course, following the right
processes only matters if it's a process that's
convenient to Donald Trump that Donald Trump
likes.
Otherwise it doesn't matter.
It's whatever Trump wants.
Now, the bigger question here is actually
whether William Barr was involved in some
way in the Ukraine fiasco because I want to
be really clear here in this latest story.
The question is why did BARR refuse to do
what Trump asked and isn't bar a great guy
for refusing to do it?
But one of the things that William Barr was
quick to do from the time that the Ukraine
story broke was to immediately distance himself
from any involvement in it.
And it's not clear that William Barr wasn't
involved because remember in the phone call
with the Ukrainian president Zelenskyi, at
least in the parts that Trump released in
the bogus partial transcript, Trump refers
to, I'm going to have William Barr get in
touch with Ukrainian prosecutors to look into
Hillary's emails and to look into Joe Biden.
As far as Trump is saying in the call, William
Barr was involved or was soon going to be
involved.
Now, of course, the justice department is
maintaining that.
The first time bar ever heard about any of
this was when the partial transcript was released,
but does anybody believe that that, does anybody
think that that is the most likely scenario?
There are reports that bar was regularly pulled
into things like this before, including one
instance where Donald Trump spoke on the phone
with the Australian prime minister, Scott
Morrison and Trump told Morrison, Hey, can
you help my attorney general William Barr
gather information to help us investigate
Robert Mueller.
If you can imagine, there's a report of William
Barr meeting with Italian officials about
other investigations meant to be favorable
to Donald Trump.
There are reports that William Barb was in
touch with British intelligence officials
under strange circumstances and for opaque
purposes.
So every indication here is that William Barr
is just as dirty as Trump and this entire
thing.
So allowing William Barr to come away as the
ethical one because he didn't go out there
and say the president broke no laws, something
which would've been a stretch even for William
Barr to do about something which he had not
investigated.
We can skip that altogether and let's keep
the focus on the important issue that is at
hand here, which is it seems like William
Barr is involved in all of this Trumpy and
nonsense.
He may be part of the problem and if so, if
this actually becomes a matter for the justice
department, William Barr needs to recuse himself.
There are actually already calls from legal
scholars saying anything even remotely associated
with Donald Trump and Ukraine and Biden corruption,
whatever the case may be, if it's even remotely
associated with that, William Barr cannot
oversee it.
He needs to recuse himself because he appears
to be just as involved as Rudy Giuliani, Giuliani,
call him.
What you will.
Um, and a lot of these other people that have
been slowly but surely pulled into it, of
course they're not going to do it.
Donald Trump.
Donald Trump has already made clear that when
attorney generals, when attorneys general
recuse themselves from things that involve
Trump, they end up losing their jobs as a
Jeff sessions is proof of, by the way, Jeff
sessions is running for Senate.
Again, we will talk about that on the bonus
show.
But for now we will take a quick break.
Make sure to give us a like on Facebook at
facebook.com/david
Pakman show and follow me on tick tock.
What are we doing on ticktock?
I don't know.
But we're on there at David Pakman show on
TechTalk,